d'abord monsieur stage c'est un plaisir
de vous accueillir sur fion si je vous
demandais ce soir monsieur le stage de
qualifier la situation de quelques et
dans quelle situation financière se
trouve transat en ce moment vous me
diriez quoi je vous dirais que compte
tenu des circonstances extraordinaires
c'est pas si mal
et puis comme ça fait vous savez 42 ans
qui à la fin ça fait j'ai passé toutes
les crises en commençant par la guerre
du golfe en 90 la première pierre du
gage nous allons passer à travers cette
crise là d'une façon ou d'une autre
est ce que fait votre crise cela dit la
plus importante que vous affrontez oui
effectivement c'est la crise
le plus importante que j'ai affrontée de
moteur et est ce que celle fille je
m'excuse de vous poser la question
directement comme ça mais est ce que
ceci pourrait être fatale pour une
entreprise comme la vôtre
non non nous n'ont absolument pas nous
allons d'abord il ya la transaction je
suppose qu'on va parler et vous allez
m'en parler de quelques secondes faire
texte j'en doute pas et puis
deuxièmement je dirais transaction ou la
transaction transalta et continuera à
exister d'une façon ou d'une autre
mais bon on va on va y venir à la
transaction mais parlons simplement de
l'état des choses devaient annoncer
quand même des pertes et une baisse de
revenus au dernier trimestre là vous
parlez de reprise des activités le 23
juillet mais les frontières restent
fermés et encore énormément
d'incertitudes
pendant combien de temps vous pouvez
naviguer dans cette dans cette
incertitude pendant combien de temps
transat peu patienter avant une reprise
de certaines activités
d'abord nous notre plan d'affaires si
vous voulez prévoit que nous allons
continuer
et effectivement nous ne prévoyons pas
que dès le 23 juillet car nous
recommencerons noval dès le premier jour
nous serons un tableau loin de là
c'était évident mais on en a l'argent
nécessaire on a les équipes nécessaires
on a fait ce qu'il fallait faire
qui était important pour la survie de
transat et puis on va on va continuer
comme on l'a toujours fait donc est ce
qu'il est possible quand même que
l'entreprise soit obligé de se placer
sous la protection des tribunaux n'ont
nullement question ce même par quelques
changements dans les usages 23 juillet
pour la reprise de 23 liaison est ce que
vous pensez que les clients seront au
rendez vous ça c'est une très très bonne
question alors d'après toutes les études
qu'on a un qu'on a vu les clients
veulent voyager et particulièrement les
clients qu'on appelle un millier
familles et les clients loisirs
il faut savoir que c'est notre clientèle
de base c'est l'adn de transat donc les
clients vont être là nous allons prendre
toutes les mesures évidemment sanitaires
pour que cela se passe bien et nous
allons donc reprendre nos opérations
c'était évident que les bonnes soupes
populaires au début rien on se rend
compte ya une volonté des gens de
vouloir voyager je pense le confinement
tout le monde comment cette année comme
on dit et donc
je suis très très confiant que ça va
fonctionner vous n'avez pas la certitude
cela dit que le 23 juillet ce sera
possible d'aller de l'avant mais une
certitude non je mettrais pas ma main au
feu là dedans mais là dessus mais cela
étant dit si vous remarquez d'abord la
plupart des transporteurs ont prévu le
1er juillet lit gouvernement sont
tranquillement en train de descons fini
il ya même la france qui a annoncé hier
que le 1er juillet salaires comores
c'est donc on est et nous nous avons
pris un peu de sécurité trois semaines
de plus pour voir commencer nos
opérations et comme je vous dis les
clients sont là sur une échelle de 1 à
10 j'y vais de façon un peu simpliste là
mais c'est pour se donner une image
claire disent par exemple étant
absolument certain de 1 à 10 quelles
sont les vraies possibilités que la
transaction avec air canada aille de
l'avant
bah écoutez chose ce sera difficile pour
moi de répondre à cette question l'un
d'eux a dit cela mais aujourd'hui nous
sommes promis à la transaction
nous notre conseil d'administration nos
actionnaires ont décidé à 95% pour cette
transaction là nous ont tous deux façons
respecté toutes les conditions de la
transaction et de l'autre côté la partie
fait la même chose donc pour l'instant
alors c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de rumeurs
mais moi je discuterai pas des rues main
aujourd'hui j'ai une transaction sur la
table c'est tout le monde est d'accord
avec ça non nous sommes commis à la
transition mais de bureau le bureau de
la concurrence a fait savoir que l'achat
de transat par air canada pourrait avoir
une incidence négative sur 83 liaison
dont 49 entre le canada et l'europe la
commission européenne également étudie
la chose et air canada aussi à des défis
financiers
quel est votre conviction profonde que
cette transaction nouveau marché va
écouter bureau de la concurrence
jouer son rôle c'est pas le bureau de la
concurrence qui va décider de la
transfert je m'en sers gouvernement et
ses deux ministres des transports etc 2
qui doit faire une recommandation au
cabinet par rapport à la transaction par
rapport à la commission donc nous
attendons si vous voulez la décision du
gouvernement par rapport à ce dossier là
et nous sommes confiants d'obtenir les
autorisations je pensais au canada aussi
ça marche pas admettons que ça marche
pas en est-on qu' il peut y avoir
plusieurs plusieurs raisons pour
lesquelles ça marche pas première raison
il pourrait avoir la raison du full
black est prévu dans notre formation
d'engagement entre actionnaires avec air
canada full black c'est à dire le
gouvernement refuse la transaction d'un
million merci bonjour et nous
continuerons notre travail va continuer
shahzad est là depuis trente trois ans
comme société publique 42 ans que j'ai
fondé cette ambition elle va continuer
demain matin tout le monde est prêt les
avions sont là on a le bon type
d'appareil on a le 3 21 et hollande
ranch qui est le type idéal d'après on a
une très bonne équipe on a déployé
dévoué à l'entreprise on s'est amélioré
au niveau des revenus
ce que nous reprocher un certain moment
donné avec vous je vais terminer là
dessus nous respectons malheureusement
est ce que vous avez besoin de soutien
du gouvernement du québec et de françois
legault donc du gouvernement du québec
le cofondateur de travail oui c'est
surtout besoin des gouvernements pour
spécifiquement du gouvernement du québec
par rapport au dossier que vous
connaissez qui est le dossier et des
déremboursements aux clients comme
toutes les compagnies aériennes au monde
ont obtenu des aides gouvernementales
nous demandons au gouvernement de nous
aider
pas à traverser cette situation
inimaginable et incroyants absolument
monsieur la tâche merci beaucoup bonne
chance pour la suite
merci monsieur fignon